PAUL NEWSON: You want to build
the next wildly popular app.
But there's a bunch
of different places
to store data in the Cloud.
You're probably asking yourself,
where should I store my stuff?
Well, that depends.
What does your stuff look like?
If it kind of
looks like a table,
then Cloud Datastore
is the right fit.
If it looks more like these
unstructured bags of bytes,
the Cloud Storage is
where it should go.
Most apps have
both types of data
and we use both of
these storage systems.
Both give you
massive scalability
and zero administration.
Both can be used by code running
on App Engine, Compute Engine,
or on your clients.
With Cloud Datastore, you
get queries and transactions
without having to
find a scam upfront.
Cloud Storage lets you
store as many blobs
as you want of practically
unlimited size.
This combination does
most of what you'll need.
So if you're writing
code from scratch,
this is the place to start.
Now, while the combination of
Cloud Datastore pulse Cloud
Storage is awesome,
and covers most needs,
sometimes you'll need or want
something more specialized.
Cloud Datastore is able to
provide massive scalability
by using a data model that is
different from the traditional
relational database model.
This is sometimes
called a NoSQL database.
If you need or want a
fully relational database,
Cloud SQL has you covered, with
a fully managed MySQL solution.
If you need to perform ad hoc
analysis of massive data sets
with absolutely
jaw-dropping speed,
you could load your data
from other Cloud products
into BigQuery.
You owe it to yourself to
take BigQuery for a spin.
You'll be amazed
at what it can do.
It's built on the same
technology we use here
at Google to query
our data, which
is about as big
as big data gets.
Maybe you're already
using a storage solution
you're happy with.
In that case, it'll run
great on Compute Engine,
and can store it's data
on persistent disk.
If you want to build an app
that interacts with user data
stored in Google Drive or
has awesome collaboration
features like you've
seen in Google Apps,
then you should check
out the Google Drive API.
So where should you
store your stuff?
Start with Cloud Datastore
for structured data and Cloud
Storage for unstructured data.
Then layer in the other storage
technologies as you need them.
Need relational data?
Cloud SQL.
Need analysis?
BigQuery.
Already have a storage
solution you like?
Run it on Compute Engine
with persistent disk.
Want collaborative editing?
Check out Google Drive.
Now you know where
to store your stuff,
go build something great.